the jurgen experience there will be no
like secrets
within 20 years there will be zero
secrets of anything in your mind
you won't even be able to keep thought
secret within 20 years right because
they they'll figure out a way just to
like
read just to do it man just to know what
the neural energy is inside of your
brain
pick it up yeah and then translate it
anyone driving by people that's oh my
god it's coming that tinfoil that's when
truly people are gonna have to start
wearing stupid helmets
imagine if that's what really works it's
not tin foil but it's one of those um
what are those things called the uh
you put your phone into and then a
faraday cage yeah it's like a faraday
cage faraday so that it is a tinfoil hat
instead of a tinfoil hat it's a faraday
hat and when you see someone wearing it
you're like there goes a liar
look at them with their [ __ ] liars
helmet on they have to wear that so we
don't know what they're really thinking
but what if the hackers get a hold of
that and make
like influential programs that go into
your [ __ ] memories and and change
memories like well we have these digital
memories but we also have filters shut
the [ __ ] up someone already made one of
these this is the best day of their life
by the way faraday cap oh my god they
have one lamb's faraday cap wave stopper
technology 99
uv and wireless radiation why do i think
it's hot that she would believe that
right a pretty girl that has a faraday
hat on that's cool like yeah she's so
crazy she believes the government's
trying to wire her i like it it's
[ __ ] cool yeah
oh it's better it's like that that's
like a little red white i love that oh
this is on amazon it's only 60 bucks wow
fair radiation protection i'm gonna wear
that on stage from now on that's my new
look yeah but what happens you start
wearing that podcast we're wearing those
and our and all of a sudden we're water
dose please
we're way more articulate imagine like
our thoughts clear up what if all of a
sudden you just feel more relaxed then
you realize oh my god it's electronic
interception just like jesus christ like
how it's [ __ ] up bees
yeah you know they think cell phone
signals are [ __ ] bees up yeah because
they think it's like a constant
jackhammer
they're like whoa like this [ __ ] is not
supposed to be out here they're supposed
to be out communicating somehow or
another they don't exactly know
that's so creepy man that's so sad
what's so funny
i'm not gonna say it would say it
there's a
beanie a beanie why is that so funny
you just thought it was that funny yeah
jamie did you get a contact high five
we know there's this uh tim where's that
oh tim all the time maybe he's in he
would get tim a new beanie maybe against
5g cell towers smart meters and wi-fi
maybe that's what uh
maybe he's ahead of the game keep your
family protected you should keep your
family protected you gotta need your
[ __ ] kids to wear beanies
yeah man oh we gotta get a beanie well
we should definitely get a hood well why
don't you start making them
jre faraday cat cages it's called a very
touch and go brain coat oh nice like you
look at night shielding for your mind
you're a knight of the digital war there
you go oh
that's a faraday cage that's oh for
hunting that way i could really be one
with nature without any influence
avoid government spying and look you can
keep your phone in that pocket right
near your ear
the earmuff looks like a cell phone
pocket doesn't leave a pocket
just just answer your phone from right
there hello duncan speaking
there's like a little hole where the
microphone is at the bottom oh god i
love it man i i i'm actually there's a
whole industry out there for these
things of course it's pretty fascinating
let's get ready for faraday cage
underwear because i know those are out
there too
right i mean that makes more sense to me
a dick sheath something to keep the emf
out of your dick yeah like a jock strap
like some kind of a harness 100 that
makes more sense in the house they have
it there they go there you go it's
already there
where where do we got here all of it
those are faraday cage yup faraday
underwear fairy tales
that's you give that to your girl so
baby it's the same company lambs they're
all over it
that's crazy man you said baby this
[ __ ] can't be on an open network we got
to close you to that digital signal
cage over that puzzle
anti-radiation underwear anti-radiation
thunder oh that i mean i don't know if
that's a bad idea is it testicular
cancer survivor i think it's a good idea
do you think that the the radiation that
you get from cell phones gives people
cancer or could i don't answer that
because we're on a podcast
what do you mean we don't know i'm like
don't answer that what i would it's a
terrible question to answer oh you but
you i think you're allowed to go
i don't know and then say maybe it's
this right like we don't clearly we
don't know
i don't know but i know that like before
i got testicular games i played a lot of
[ __ ] world of warcraft on a laptop
right on my dick i know that jesus
christ did is that what did it who knows
but i would imagine
keeping like a powerful
thing that's radiating energy
over your balls
it's probably not the best idea right
that's not the best idea no try to get a
little separation there i don't think
that's crazy or anything